[Music]
it's the Moe's Christmas is a magical
time full of wonder excitement and joy a
time for making lasting memories with
family and friends the Dean of the
secret behind what makes Christmas so
special mom's mom's working their asses
off cookie
wrapping decorating and shopping from
like November to New Year's this is our
busiest time of the year at work I waxed
39 [ __ ] today who's next
oh my god since when and every woman in
America need a completely hairless
vagina on Christmas I spend months
picking out the perfect present for
everyone you know the only thing I get
in return
coupons for free back rubs that's not
okay shitty back rubs remember when the
holidays were actually fun it doesn't
say Christmas back
[Music]
come on where's your tree I didn't want
to waste time Christmas tree shopping I
actually just wanted to enjoy Christmas
this year maybe you're a mom moms don't
enjoy they give joy that's how being a
mom works thank you your dad is awesome
why would you say that I heard you and
Daddy in the bedroom
you come screaming those were just there
were happy screams and then you punch
the wall and yells the effort you were
like oh my [ __ ] god just like that oh
my [ __ ] god
[Music]